voilà monsieur bonsoir bienvenue au
paradis c'est en ces termes que le
représentant de jean paul ii a salué la
mémoire de mère teresa ce matin à
calcutta
l'inde a fait des obsèques nationales à
cette religieuse de 87 ans surnommée la
madone des bidonvilles après une vie de
dévouement auprès des plus démunis
françois corner sur le camion kaki pracc
temps le catafalque un face-à-face
étonnant ce matin dans les rues de
calcutta
entre les petites soeurs des
missionnaires de la charité et les
soldats de l'armée indienne
les funérailles nationales en effet pour
la somme des pauvres dans l'enceinte du
stade mais hadji toutes les religions
sont représentées pour la célébration de
cette cérémonie funèbre protestants
hindous musulmans sikhs ou bouddhistes
unis dans un même hommage à la
religieuse catholique que l'archevêque
de canterbury qualifiera d'ange de la
paix règne président épouses de chefs
d'état ministre assistent à ces obsèques
du prix nobel de la paix qui a consacré
sa vie comme le rappellera les preuves
aux damnés de la terre
la france était représentée par
bernadette chirac et bernard kouchner
les états unis par hillary clinton
le représentant du pape le cardinal
angelo sodano a lu un hommage de jean
paul ii à la petites soeurs des pauvres
qui a allumé dans ce monde je cite une
flamme d'amour offrandes des déshérités
une orpheline un lépreux et un aveugle à
leur madone de calcutta soeur nirmala
qui a pris la succession de mère teresa
à la tête des missionnaires de la
charité a demandé à l'assemblée de prier
pour que l'ordre garde la même
détermination dans son combat pour les
pauvres
mon action n'est qu'une goutte d'eau
dans l'océan disait mère teresa mais ce
sont les gouttes d'eau qui forment un
océan dépôt de couronnes au nom de la
france par bernadette chirac et bernard
kouchner au pied du cercueil blanc
recouvert du drapeau indien
safran blanc et vert autre image
surprenante de ses obsèques
les religieuses qui accompagne mère
teresa jusqu'à sa dernière demeure au
son de la cornemuse
c'est à l'intérieur de la maison de la
mer comme on surnomme le siège de la
congrégation des missionnaires de la
charité que mère teresa a été inhumé les
soldats d'élite de l'armée indienne lui
ont rendu les honneurs par quatre salles
de 32 coupe-feu 4 clairon ont ensuite
sonné l'adieu aux armes marquant la fin
de cette cérémonie selon une estimation
de la police locale près d'un million de
personnes se sont donc que massée sur le
passage du cortège funèbre un peu moins
que certains ne l'attendait ou ne
l'espérait nous retrouvons direct de
calcutta l'un de nos envoyés spéciaux
benoît duquesne qui a vécu cette journée
de recueillement
oui tout à fait et vous disiez 1
millions officiellement selon services
de comptage locaux et alors qu'on
attendait un million et demi de
personnes c'était les chiffres il tente
en tout cas annoncé hier lors pourquoi
cette différence est bien peut-être tout
simplement parce que beaucoup de gens
n'ont pas osé tout simplement venir à
cette cérémonie
parce que il se sentait trop petit trop
humble pour y participer dans la mesure
où cet événement et pris des proportions
qui dépassent et complètement avec un
run retentissement international
et puis aussi peut-être parce que les
obsèques nationales organisées par le
gouvernement est indien et bien tout
cela avec ses pompes et ses fastes les a
de fait un peu exclu même si au fond
d'eux mêmes ils se sentaient très fiers
d'aller le voir et que ce reportage de
franck le bruit c'est et de philippe
denoyelle
enterré au coeur même de sa famille dans
la maison mère de cet ordre qu'elle a
créée mère teresa est ici chez les siens
chez ceux qu'elle a aidé et soutenu
encouragé et ça se sent la foulée g et
recueillie car ce matin quand son corps
franchi les grilles de l'église
saint-thomas après huit jours de veille
quand l'armée le prend en charge peu
nombreux sont les gens de calcutta qui
ont pu accéder à cette petite rue en
face de l'église l'état un lien déploie
ses fastes pour rendre hommage à la
femme mère il faut donc que le
cérémonial soit à la hauteur de
l'événement sans débordement ni dérapage
seuls les très proches de mère teresa
pourront l'accompagner dans ce dernier
voyage à travers la ville soeur nirmala
qui lui a succédé à la tête de l'ordre
et sera nièce qui fête à laquelle dès le
début la foule est massée un peu plus
loin le long des barrières de bambou
quelle que soit leur religion hindoue
musulmans ou chrétiens tous veulent
saluer le dévouement et l'amour de celle
du le considère comme une salle elle a
tant fait pour les pauvres gens ce
qu'ils n'ont droit à rien qu'ils sont
sans nourriture sans toi elle s'en est
occupé mais a relevé
elle leur a donné l'amour l'amour de
dieu seuls quelques privilégiés peuvent
assister à la cérémonie officielle à
condition d'oser faire la queue le stade
est petit et les places sont rares
elle était en mission pour tout le monde
y compris les plus jeunes
maintenant il ya bien des distractions
comme le cinéma ou bien la politique
mais elle c'était autre chose
à nous de suivre son chemin d'aimer son
prochain des mails humanité
à l'intérieur les personnalités les pays
paie comme on dit ici et des
représentants des indigents des lépreux
des orphelins ces pauvres quelle mère
teresa a consacré sa vie et qu'elle
aurait sans doute voire plus nombreux à
ses obsèques
dehors la foule attend toujours il pleut
comme toujours pendant la mousson
on boit du thé du café on mange des
bonbons le corps de mère teresa quitte
alors ces beaux quartiers de calcutta où
elle fit ses débuts comme religieuse
pour arriver à sa maison mère
là où elle a commencé sa seconde vie à
près de 50 ans en créant les
missionnaires de la charité
elle laisse derrière elle de sari blanc
bordées de bleu un chapelet une proie
un pull bleu pour l'hiver et un
parapluie pour la mousson et 4500
membres répartis dans 160 pays
heureusement que leurs intérêts la mise
en mer incidents seront très très grand
vide
alors est-ce au milieu de vous ce qui
compte 10 et mère teresa
ce n'est pas de faire beaucoup c'est de
mettre beaucoup d'amour dans ce qu'on
fait
vous parlez des personnalités de celles
qui sont venus à la cérémonie
certaines d'entre elles en fin d'après
midi se sont rendus comme la mère de la
reine d'espagne comme bernadette chirac
ou comme monsieur kouchner dans certains
des centres avec avait créé ici mère
teresa et notamment dans le plu le
premier d'entre eux le plus célèbre
celui où tout a commencé le fameux
mouroir de qualibat un mou voire
contesté par certains qui reproche à la
mère teresa dit avoir accueilli mais
mourant et de ne leur avoir prodigué
aucun soin les choses sembleraient avoir
changé depuis puisque les soeurs disent
maintenant que les soins sont
effectivement prodigués aux mourants
mais déjà à l'époque mère teresa balayer
tout ça d'un revers de la main ils ont
écouté pendant que vous disserter sur la
façon d'accompagner les pauvres dans la
mort et bien moi je fais ce que je peux
alors pouvoir commencer par les gens des
bidonvilles mais en tout cas les gens
des quartiers populaires ont suivi ses
obsèques etc elle le souvenir ils
garderont de mère teresa
martine laroche-joubert bernard gonflé
et jean paul fourrey se sont rendus dans
le quartier de tenda un ancien chauffeur
de mère teresa a roof un privilégié dans
le quartier populaire où il habite il
ramène un salaire de 1600 roupies par
mois 300 francs
marié deux enfants
il vient chez lui ce matin regarder à la
télévision
les obsèques de mère teresa en compagnie
de ses voisins qui comme la majorité des
indiens n'ont pas de poste
elles ne regardaient pas les lépreux
comme des malades elle et prenait dans
ses bras et s'en occuper elle même elle
n'est plus là aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
seulement moi et tous les indiens qui
sont tristes
beaucoup n'ont pas osé aller se
recueillir dans l'église ou mère teresa
reposer ni à l'enterrement
ford officielles qui d un timide je n'ai
jamais rencontré mais j'aurais bien aimé
la voir
il n'y a personne comme l inde on
n'oubliera jamais ce qu'il a fait pour
nous avoue et sa famille habitent dans
le quartier de khalida où la déesse
durga protège ses adorateurs ici aussi
merkel les a décidé elle de petits
hôtels qui lui sont consacrés sont
dressés à chaque fois devenu je suis
allé dans l'école que mère teresa a
construite de votre quartier les gens
très reconnaissants de ce qu'il a fait
il n'y a pas seulement une tristesse
international aujourd'hui c'est une pré
perte personnelle
on prie dieu pour la paix de sonam avec
les pluies de la mousson l'eau envahit
très vite tout le quartier
une indienne nous en train de chez elle
mère teresa et ségur en bonne place une
autre mère on ne trouve aucune
comparaison avec ce qu'elle a fait elle
nous les pauvres
elle nous encourager elle a créé des
hôpitaux des écoles et des orphelinats
qu'ils soient chrétiens
adou musulmans y pertes aujourd'hui mère
teresa
le réconfort c'est la rade né restera
gravé dans leur coeur
alors on a beaucoup parlé également
depuis la mort de mère teresa on a
beaucoup parlé de ses positions très
tranchées réactionnaire sur des
questions aussi fondamentales que
l'avortement est ici la contraception
dans ce pays qui compte près d'un
milliard d'habitants et je veux dire que
ici c'est pas du tout l'impression que
ça nous a fait les gens n'ont semble
surtout avoir retenu deux mère teresa
l'immense message d'amour que la
prodigués ici en inde et pour l'ensemble
du monde
c'est à peu près je crois tout ce qu'on
pouvait dire renault ce soir ici à
calcutta
après la cérémonie des obsèques de mère
teresa merci benoît duquesne d'un
enterrement l'autre ce samedi le même
jour l'ancien président tout puissant du
zaïre mobutu sese seko et est inhumé
dans la plus stricte intimité pour ne
pas dire en catimini décédé dimanche
dernier d'un cancer à l'âge de 66 ans le
maréchal mobutu a été enterré dans un
caveau du cimetière européen de rabat
aucun diplomate ou représentants des
anciens pays alliés du zaïre à commencer
par la france n'a officiellement assisté
à ses obsèques en france la disparition
à l'âge de 84 ans de roger frey ancien
ministre et ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel
compagnon de la première heure du
général de gaulle roger frey appartenait
au groupe des barons du gaullisme avec
entre autres jacques chaban-delmas
michel debré ou encore olivier guichard
roger frey avait participé au
gouvernement pendant près de quatorze
ans de 59 à 72 record de longévité
ministérielle sous la vème république
depuis près de 70 ans est l'un des
grands rituels de la vie politique
française la fête de l'humanité le grand
rendez-vous des militants et des
sympathisants du pc en raison de
l'actualité la vedette du jour était le
ministre du transport jean claude
gayssot
reportage à la courneuve françoise david
eric de lannion
lou d'accusation le mot qui fait peur à
bon nombre de militants communistes
notamment syndiqués privatisation
ouverture de capital comme à france
télécom cela mobilise à la fête de
l'humanité
et l'on n'est souvent pas d'accord même
avec un gouvernement de gauche
les évolutions en concertation ne peut
pas apporter de votre solution au
problème en luttant contre nous sommes
confrontés de ce point de vue l'histoire
est imparable
mais moi je lui parle la mie câline
gouvernement le flou me luc amblard cgt
famille tallis indépendant alors un peu
plus loin au buffet de la gare le
ministre communiste des transports jean
claude gayssot tombe la veille et le
dialogue en effet ne sera pas facile
notamment sur la france je te demande
caméra ministre de vérifier ses comptes
parce que c'est extrêmement grave pour
nous et bataille là est bien le camarade
une liste ils essayent de la mener mais
il n'a même pas en regardant dans le
rétroviseur il a mais la russie en
devoir maintenant ce qu'on va faire
ensemble avec des salariés les salariés
qu'il fera bien convaincre le parti
communiste ne se renie pas fier mais ses
dirigeants mais il regarde vers l'avenir
il est au gouvernement pour que les
choses changent bush quitte à s'adapter
aux nouvelles réalités économiques
c'est le message que robert hue tentera
de faire passer dimanche lors de son
grand discours innovation de ce soir à
la fête de l'humanité avec la diffusion
d'une cassette enregistrée à ramallah
par yasser arafat sur place a noté un
nouveau raid de l'aviation israélienne
contre des positions de l'armée
libanaise dans le sud du pays six
soldats et une famille les auraient été
tués lors de cette attaque héliportée la
61e depuis début de cette année d'autre
part le fils du chef du mouvement
hezbollah auraient trouvé la mort lors
d'un affrontement dans la zone
frontalière avec des militaires
israéliens
l'élection municipale en bosnie
herzégovine sous haute protection de 36
mille soldats de l'otan la régularité du
scrutin étant surveillé de très près par
2500 observateurs de l'osce a eu un
scrutin marqué par quelques incidents et
des appels au boycott à sarajevo en
revanche cette journée de vote a été
calme
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
bernard lebrun à lundi
pas de problème
bonjour hockey le retour éclair au
village pour voter s'est bien passé on
les appelle les déplacés ils sont croit
tout musulman réfugiés à sarajevo
car là bas dans la vallée il y à pas les
élus radicaux serbes occupent leur
maison grâce à la protection militaire
ils ont pu faire cette première visite
au pays depuis la guerre franchement je
ne peux pas dire qu'il ya eu des
incidents les gens du village qui nous
ont reconnus sont bienvenus les
conditions parfaites heureux d'approcher
de palais j'espère que cela va continuer
comme ça un jour revenir à palets gorba
vide ça l'ancien quartier serbe de
sarajevo
là aussi on a tout fait pour organiser
la réciproque afin que toutes les
ethnies vivent dans la sérénité
sous le regard quelquefois un peu perdu
les observateurs de l'osce et haut il
n'y a plus beaucoup de serbes à sarajevo
sauf quelques personnes âgées qui n'ont
jamais voulu bouger
et tout le monde devra faire comme moi
oui c'est toutes les nationalités sont
venus voter
les représentants de tous les partis qui
sont ici avec vous diront la même chose
la première dans ces files d'attentes
parfois très longue
toutes les ethnies se sont côtoyés que
l'on s'inquiétait bien sûr des futurs
résultats officiellement durant pense
dans dix jours après les élections
vers le 21 pourquoi un délai aussi long
parce qu'on va être sûr que tous les
résultats sont bons et que comme
aujourd'hui en bosnie rien de sérieux ne
soit venu perturber le scrutin
un chiffre très attendu qui celui là
sera connu dès lundi
la participation selon les derniers
sondages réalisés cette semaine
72% des bosniaques disaient vouloir
participer à ces élections
parmi eux 36 % étaient indécis et ce
sont ces indécis qui vont faire la
différence
les ministres des finances des quinze
sont réunis à huis clos tout ce week end
au luxembourg pour mettre au point
l'entrée en vigueur de l'euro toujours
prévue pour le 1er janvier 99
d'autre part les 15 grands argentiers
ont ouvert à nouveau le très délicate
dossier chantier de l'harmonisation
fiscale au sein de l'union européenne
l'aéroport de roissy charles de gaulle
devrait être doté dans les prochaines
années de deux nouvelles pistes la
capacité maximale de cet aéroport
passerait alors de 80 à 120 atterrissage
décollage par heure la décision du
gouvernement pas encore officiel mais
dit-on irréversible provoque la colère
des associations de riverains le point
fidi sérias alain dubé ce qui d'un côté
il y à roissy charles de gaulle saturé
l'aéroport peine accueillir un trafic
qui augmentent de 4% par an il faudrait
donc augmenter le nombre des pistes ça
ça dépend du ministère des transports
le ministre affirme est aujourd'hui
qu'aucune décision n'était encore prise
pas falloir dans les prochains mois
concertée à l'échelle du pays pour voir
ce qui sera nécessaire de faire de toute
manière pour répondre à la demande
nationale et internationale qui est
devant nous par ailleurs il y a les
riverains
usant quotidienne qu'il faudrait limiter
ça ça dépend du ministère de
l'aménagement du territoire et de
l'environnement madame wayne et
reconnaît qu'il y a peu d'espoir
d'empêcher la construction des pistes
s'est créé sous la responsabilité du
ministre des transports et la ministre
d'environnement n'a pas la possibilité
de décider sur un sujet de cette ampleur
dépendamment de la perte des transports
pour limiter les dégâts madame voynet
propose des mesures visant à réduire le
bruit des avions
mais pour les riverains ça ne changera
rien le mal est fait il va y avoir 10
milliards dans les infrastructures
routières et ferroviaires par qui ne
restera plus ici un push de terrains
disponibles
les travaux de construction des pistes
sont gelés depuis le 15 juillet dernier
pour concertation
réponse définitive vers le 20 septembre
du rififi chez les éleveurs de porcs
bretons dans son combat contre
l'agriculture intensive la confédération
paysanne la grande rivale de la fnsea
s'en prend en effet aux gros éleveurs et
plus particulièrement à ceux qui ont
agrandi leur cheptel de façon tout à
fait illégale et qui se voient
aujourd'hui amnistiés témoin cette
opération spectaculaire menée
aujourd'hui près de loudéac est sur
place jacques devaux gabriel kenya
le bonheur est dans le pré pour ses
cochons qui ne connaissent d'ordinaire
que le sol cimenté de la porcherie une
porcherie de plus de 1000 tri qui selon
la confédération paysanne est exemplaire
de la dérive productiviste de rêver
l'éleveur
déjà condamné pour avoir illégalement a
grandi sa porcherie se voit aujourd'hui
à nice qui non seulement son élevage est
devenu légal mais il peut prétendre
toucher des subventions on admet que
certaines personnes puissent avoir
dépassé un petit peu mais quand un
élevage a doublé dans la partie légale
qu'il doit être sanctionné on ne doit
pas au moins lui donner les aides pour
sa mise aux normes et il doit libérer
laisser les hectares pour l'épandage des
voisins qui eux ont besoin de s'agrandir
et notamment des jeunes qui veulent
s'installer qu'on la confédération
paysanne cette action est aussi un appel
ou un public
accusé de favoriser une agriculture trop
intensive ce type d'élevage industriel
quant à la place de caisse familles
paysannes donc c'est clair qu'au travers
de ce cas là nulle autre de montrer
qu'il est temps il ya moyen de faire une
autre agriculture de produits sans doute
autant d'animaux en bretagne mais
réparties différemment ce territoire
les agriculteurs n'étaient pas seuls les
consommateurs se sont jointes à l'action
pour le collectif bretagne eau pure
c'est une question d'équité
la redevance pollution qui figure sur la
facture d'eau va servir à financer
je dirai ce fameux programme de maîtrise
de pollutions d'origine agricole
or nous voulons bien aider l'agriculture
mais si on nous ment pas dans n'importe
quelle condition
la manifestation s'est déroulée dans le
calme pas de casse les forces de l'ordre
ne sont pas intervenues
au même moment dominique voynet visiter
un salon des produits bio à quelques
kilomètres de là le message est passé
son chef de cabinet a rencontré les
manifestants à monaco ce week end est
l'occasion du traditionnel rassemblement
de vieux canaux avec exceptionnellement
cette année ont raison du 700e
anniversaire de la principauté
la présence dans les eaux de monte-carlo
de voiliers du début du siècle
reportage yasmina farber diane richard
un prince des mers en principauté un
fameux 4 m'a baptisé sedov le plus grand
voilier du monde l'ont 217 m quatre
mille 150 mètres carrés de voile ce
bateau école russe c'est bien sûr
l'invité de prestige de ce rendez-vous
marin à monaco walt sur la mer couronne
sur les quais le prince albert fait
visiter tuiga le voyez du yacht-club à
juan carlos roi d'espagne une ambiance
courtoise et élégante où naviguent des
marins comme catherine chabaud plus
habitué aux sports du vendée globe je
crois qu'il n'en bien ce qui est dû
d'une part à ces bateaux qui sont des
bateaux traditions et ses propriétaires
et puis à une ambiance qui est dû à
monaco sans doute donc
c'est très ambiance yachting c'est
amusant un jeu qui séduit les
collectionneurs de ces beaux bateaux
c'est le cas d'hugo barra val il va
participer au concours d'élégance sur
isla un cruiser de 1922 la nec sous les
dames regarder leurs hommes régatent et
7 italiens possèdent dix bateaux un
hobby hors de prix pour un plaisir
esthétique mais trompeuse et les choses
dans tous les domaines pas seulement
d'aller voir passer des choses qui
n'étaient pas allés à
au besoin on composait belle chose pour
mes belles choses mais les belles choses
futiles ne fonctionne pas toujours
moteur en rade il sait reste à quai
pendant le défilé place aux cannois
vapeur
monaco on retrouve son ambiance du début
de siècle le charme de la belle époque
entre insouciance primé passion passion
pour ces bateaux ont tourné au cuivre et
bois verni cette élégante nostalgie
règnera en principauté jusqu'à dimanche
prochain au fil des années le deltaplane
a perdu de nombreux adeptes au profit du
parapente l'est le delta étant jugée
plus risquée est moins facile d'accès
dans les pyrénées un passionné de ce
sport loisir a mis au point un système
d'apprentissage aussi sécurisant
qu'étonnant comme l'ont constaté sur
place muriel la saga et jb ruse aile
delta c'est l'homme oiseau un grand
frisson accessible à tous surtout quand
le plancher des vaches n'est plus qu'à
quelques mètres à droite
allez allez c'est la réplique intégrale
d'un vol normal à part que le volet
entièrement comment dire capter captifs
cet instrument le simulateur de vol
permet de commencer par apprendre à
piloter les c'est à dire connaître l'ale
colette ses sensations et apprendre à la
diriger une fois pris dans la voile le
vent agit alors comme un treuil vitesse
du véhicule 55 km heure et une piste de
400 mètres parfois trop courte pour
faire durer le plaisir
mais c'est apparemment efficace pour un
début quant au contrôle de son volant
on a plus on n'a pas enchaîné le
décollage et l'atterrissage nice et ça
nous laisse beaucoup plus de temps pour
le voile en fait un vont terminer
patrick avait déjà mis au point ce
système de câbles bons fous moins
fatiguant et plus sécurisant que
l'apprentissage sur une pente école avec
le simulateur patrick touche à la
perfection du système d ça paraît au
premier abord un petit peu bricoler mais
le but c'est d'essayer de maîtriser la
sécurité du vol la sécurité du système
avec trois échelles des planches de
contreplaqué et deux ailes delta vos
cycles et patrick a réussi son pari
attirer jeunes et moins jeunes vers le
grand vide pour qui m'a même temps
centrale et retrouver la coupe d'europe
de rugby en poule d des comme des fêtes
bourgoin a pris une véritable leçon face
à l'équipe anglaise des harlequins en
poule e comme exploit pour a battu
largement les gallois commentaires
franchement quand on joue contre les
harlequins il faut s'attendre à en voir
de toutes les couleurs à l'ombre de
truquer dame qui se dresse là bas au
fond du terrain
l'équipe de bourgoin en a vu des vertes
et des pas mûres cet après midi et tout
ça par la faute d'un compatriote thierry
lacroix l'un des quatre français de
l'équipe londonienne a passé cinq
pénalités que les anglais et même dans
une français soit supérieur le jeu au
pied ça on a l'habitude mais que l'un
des meilleurs clubs de chez nous
prennent bleus sont de voeux de
mouvement en angleterre ça c'est un peu
vexant
les harlequins ont marqué quatre essais
dont le dernier ici par woods contre un
seul à bourgoin résultat 40 5 à 7 pour
l'équipe de long
mais enfin bon il ya eu au moins un
français de comptes ans à pau on a moins
eu le sourire on s'est même battu comme
des chiens la plupart du temps du match
entre palois en blanc et gallois en mai
entre les bagarres
il ya eu du jeu entièrement al'avantage
de pau si l'essai à 0 dont deux de
nicolas brusque et une victoire 44 à 12
sur l'équipe de flâner clip
bref c'est cet exemple là que brive le
tenant du titre devra suivre demain une
enquête sur les circonstances de la mort
de la princesse diana le juge
d'instruction a délivré hier le permis
d'inhumer du corps d'henri paul le
chauffeur de la mercedes
en grande bretagne le prince charles et
ses deux fils ont tenu à remercier
derrière les britanniques qui leur ont
adressé leurs condoléances
plus de trois cent mille lettres poèmes
dessins ou encore photos sont arrivés au
palais st james à londres le prince
charles et ses enfants ont pris
l'engagement de répondre à chacun de
leurs correspondants
une semaine après la cérémonie de
westminster c'était la ruée ce matin
chez tous les disquaires de grande
bretagne avec que la mise en vente de la
chanson d'elton john spécialement écrite
pour les funérailles de son amie lady
die
la plupart des points de vente ont été
rapidement en rupture de stock
les ventes de ce cd pourrait rapporter
jusqu'à 5000 francs qui seront déversés
un fonds caritatif sorti mercredi sur
nos écrans d'un film signé par un jeune
réalisateur tchèque qui a obtenu cette
année à hollywood l'oscar du meilleur
film étranger
pauli ya c'est l'histoire d'une
rencontre pleine de rires et de
tendresse entre un vieux musiciens de
chèques et un petit garçon russe à la
veille de la révolution de 89
pascal des chants basques et le monde
découvrait la famille geyrac le fils
réalise le père sosie tchèque de sean
connery écrit et joue avec au lien il
avait conquis l'écrasante majorité des
votants
aujourd'hui ils partent à la conquête du
public l'histoire se déroule dans la
tchécoslovaquie d'avant la révolution de
velours
luca violoncelliste de 50 ans
célibataire endurci accepte de faire un
mariage arrangé avec une jeune russe
elle disparaît du jour au lendemain à
l'ouest en lui laissant un drôle de
cadeau
ces rouleaux qu'apprenti chèque oui il
est le père de sept enfants
comment le psg mais la dame qui
s'occupait de l'enfant et en bas dans
votre ambulance aviaire d'avoir une
attaque
elle nous a dit vous l'amenez voilà
c'est ça faire attendez je suis que son
père est éloigné après je voulais dire
tu pas son vrai père c'est pas le
problème
collias ou l'histoire d'une cohabitation
difficile d'une collision entre deux
planètes
entre deux êtres que tout sépare le pays
l'âge est la langue la confrontation
entre des solitudes
ce film rappelle simplement à l'heure où
les chèques construisent le capitalisme
alors tout le monde ne pense qu'à
l'argent est furax en one to qu'il ya
d'autres valeurs que si vous aimez
quelqu'un et si vous êtes aimez ou vous
ne serez jamais po ur
il y à du kid de chaplin dans ce gamin
là entre deux sanglots pour les plus
sensibles rires et sourires ne sont
jamais loin
c'est une quête il y a toujours ce
mélange de comédie et de tristesse dans
les films tchèques oms universel
délibérément grand public kolia est un
film magnifique sur lequel une
prestigieuse récompense aura attiré
l'attention et c'est tant mieux
première ce soir sur france 2 vers 22h45
de la nouvelle émission de
divertissement de christophe dechavanne
du fer dans les épinards nous retrouvons
tout de suite en direct dans son décor
le popeye de france 2 et christophe d'un
soir coucou c'est moi
alors le but c'est de tordre le cou aux
idées reçues qui vaut mieux de même que
deux temps de quoi sa belle-mère par
exemple mais qui pourrait aussi être une
idée reçue ça mais oui l'idée c'est de
se dire que la société est un peu
immobile est bloquée et que si on avait
un peu l'esprit plus ouvert les bras un
peu plus long plutôt que petits et bien
ma foi on pourrait donner un peu plus de
talent la créativité l'initiative et
tout ça est donc l'idée effectivement
c'est de tordre les idées le coup part
dans aux idées reçues est un peu d'art
est déjà toute la lumière
il ya en gros même une partie sérieuse
dirons-nous et puis une partie un peu
plus délirantes quoi en ce samedi soir
bono permettez moi de vous dire oui une
partie plutôt sérieuse au début avec
hatem un peu plus sérieux donc vous
venez de le dire qu'ils seraient toutes
les vérités sont elles bonnes à dire où
vont s'exprimer sur ce plateau des
journalistes des médecins des des élus
des anciens ministres des capteurs mems
est un peu un peu tout un tas plein
plein plein de gens et puis une deuxième
partie un peu plus un peu plus légères
on va dire un peu moins lourde avec les
hommes préfèrent les blondes alors c'est
une idée reçue est ce que c'est vrai ce
que c'est pas vrai on saura ça ce soir
avec des blondes des brunes des hommes
des filles des rousses tout ça quoi
c'est formidable ont donc rendez-vous
22h45 et bonne chance ce soir nous
sommes en lune montante monsieur
christophe on m'a dit ça c'est un bon
présage mais c'est encore au dit on une
idée reçue ici comment vous les pros ne
l'expliqué pas de problème après cricri
d'amour le tout dernier journal vers
minuit en compagnie de florence au
duprat invités de catherine ceylac
demain 7h dans thé ou café raymond devos
à midi polémique l'émission de michèle
cotta invité demain martine aubry et
puis un débat sur l'éducation nationale
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet et soleil
ch demain dimanche et à propos de
nathalie bonne fête aux aimé à demain
13h et 20h très très bonne soirée murs
m